Donald Trump has seldom been one for a
claim down so it was no surprise when he
stood firmly behind his controversial
tweets from Sunday but if you're not
happy in the u.s. if you're complaining
all the time very simply you can leave
you can leave right now but they have to
love they have to love our country their
Congress people and I never used any
names Trump may not have named names but
there appeared little doubt he was
referring to an outspoken quartet of
Congress women that calls itself the
squad
all of them US citizens three of them
born in the US and none of them white
they certainly felt singled out and
liked the president they didn't mince
their words sadly this is not the first
nor will it be the last time we hear
disgusting bigoted language from the
president I heard urge house leadership
many of my colleagues to take action to
impeach this lawless president today
he's launching a blatantly racist attack
on four duly elected members of the
United States of House of
Representatives all of whom are women of
color this is the agenda of white
nationalists despite the occupant of the
White House attempts to marginalize us
and to silence us please know that we
are more than four people
our squad includes any person committed
to building a more equitable in just
world he tells us that I should go back
to the great borough of the Bronx and
make it better
and that's what I'm here to do but even
after that response Trump was
unrepentant and back on Twitter this
time he referenced the four progressives
claiming that they hate the us-israel -
and that they are endorsing socialism
typically the president seems unruffled
by any of this among his last tweets of
the day was one containing just four
familiar words in block capitals make
America great again